is not sure what a coral is or where they come from.
How would we get someone to care about the world's coral reefs
when it's an abstract thing they can barely understand?
If they don't understand what a coral is or where it comes from,
or how funny or interesting or beautiful it is,
why would we expect them to care about saving them?
So let's change that.
What is a coral and where does it come from?
Corals are born in a number of different ways,
but most often by mass spawning: all of the individuals of a single species
on one night a year,
releasing all the eggs they've made that year
into the water column,
packaged into bundles with sperm cells.
And those bundles go to the surface of the ocean and break apart.
And hopefully -- hopefully -- at the surface of the ocean,
they meet the eggs and sperm from other corals.
And that is why you need lots of corals on a coral reef --
so that all of their eggs can meet their match at the surface.
When they're fertilized, they do what any other animal egg does:
divides in half again and again and again.
Taking these photos under the microscope every year
is one of my favorite and most magical moments of the year.
At the end of all this cell division, they turn into a swimming larva --
a little tiny blob of fat the size of a poppy seed,
but with all of the sensory systems that we have.
They can sense color and light, textures, chemicals, pH.
They can even feel pressure waves; they can hear sound.
And they use those talents
to search the bottom of the reef for a place to attach
and live the rest of their lives.
So imagine finding a place where you would live the rest of your life
when you were just two days old.
They attach in the place they find most suitable,
they build a skeleton underneath themselves,
they build a mouth and tentacles,
and then they begin the difficult work of building the world's coral reefs.
One coral polyp will divide itself again and again and again,
leaving a limestone skeleton underneath itself
and growing up toward the sun.
Given hundreds of years and many species,
what you get is a massive limestone structure
that can be seen from space in many cases,
covered by a thin skin of these hardworking animals.
Now, there are only a few hundred species of corals on the planet, maybe 1,000.
But these systems house millions and millions of other species,
and that diversity is what stabilizes the systems,
and it's where we're finding our new medicines.
It's how we find new sources of food.
I'm lucky enough to work on the island of Curaçao,
where we still have reefs that look like this.
But, indeed, much of the Caribbean and much of our world
is much more like this.
Scientists have studied in increasing detail
the loss of the world's coral reefs,
and they have documented with increasing certainty the causes.
But in my research, I'm not interested in looking backward.
My colleagues and I in Curaçao are interested in looking forward
at what might be.
And we have the tiniest reason to be optimistic.
Because even in some of these reefs
that we probably could have written off long ago,
we sometimes see baby corals arrive and survive anyway.
And we're starting to think that baby corals may have the ability
to adjust to some of the conditions that the adults couldn't.
They may be able to adjust
ever so slightly more readily to this human planet.
So in the research I do with my colleagues in Curaçao,
we try to figure out what a baby coral needs
in that critical early stage,
what it's looking for
and how we can try to help it through that process.
I'm going to show you three examples of the work we've done
to try to answer those questions.
A few years ago we took a 3D printer and we made coral choice surveys --
different colors and different textures,
and we simply asked the coral where they preferred to settle.
And we found that corals, even without the biology involved,
still prefer white and pink, the colors of a healthy reef.
And they prefer crevices and grooves and holes,
where they will be safe from being trampled
or eaten by a predator.
So we can use this knowledge,
we can go back and say we need to restore those factors --
that pink, that white, those crevices, those hard surfaces --
in our conservation projects.
We can also use that knowledge
if we're going to put something underwater, like a sea wall or a pier.
We can choose to use the materials and colors and textures
that might bias the system back toward those corals.
Now in addition to the surfaces,
we also study the chemical and microbial signals
that attract corals to reefs.
Starting about six years ago, I began culturing bacteria
from surfaces where corals had settled.
And I tried those one by one by one,
looking for the bacteria that would convince corals to settle and attach.
And we now have many bacterial strains in our freezer
that will reliably cause corals
to go through that settlement and attachment process.
So as we speak,
my colleagues in Curaçao are testing those bacteria
to see if they'll help us raise more coral settlers in the lab,
and to see if those coral settlers will survive better
when we put them back underwater.
Now in addition to these tools, we also try to uncover the mysteries
of species that are under-studied.
This is one of my favorite corals, and always has been:
dendrogyra cylindrus, the pillar coral.
I love it because it makes this ridiculous shape,
because its tentacles are fat and look fuzzy
and because it's rare.
Finding one of these on a reef is a treat.
In fact, it's so rare,
that last year it was listed as a threatened species
on the endangered species list.
And this was in part because in over 30 years of research surveys,
scientists had never found a baby pillar coral.
We weren't even sure if they could still reproduce,
or if they were still reproducing.
So four years ago, we started following these at night
and watching to see if we could figure out when they spawn in Curaçao.
We got some good tips from our colleagues in Florida,
who had seen one in 2007, one in 2008,
and eventually we figured out when they spawn in Curaçao
and we caught it.
Here's a female on the left with some eggs in her tissue,
about to release them into the seawater.
And here's a male on the right, releasing sperm.
We collected this, we got it back to the lab, we got it to fertilize
and we got baby pillar corals swimming in our lab.
Thanks to the work of our scientific aunts and uncles,
and thanks to the 10 years of practice we've had in Curaçao
at raising other coral species,
we got some of those larvae to go through the rest of the process
and settle and attach,
and turn into metamorphosed corals.
So this is the first pillar coral baby that anyone ever saw.
(Applause)
And I have to say -- if you think baby pandas are cute,
this is cuter.
(Laughter)
So we're starting to figure out the secrets to this process,
the secrets of coral reproduction and how we might help them.
And this is true all around the world;
scientists are figuring out new ways to handle their embryos,
to get them to settle,
maybe even figuring out the methods to preserve them at low temperatures,
so that we can preserve their genetic diversity
and work with them more often.
But this is still so low-tech.
We are limited by the space on our bench, the number of hands in the lab
and the number of coffees we can drink in any given hour.
Now, compare that to our other crises
and our other areas of concern as a society.
We have advanced medical technology, we have defense technology,
we have scientific technology,
we even have advanced technology for art.
But our technology for conservation is behind.
Think back to the most difficult job you ever did.
Many of you would say it was being a parent.
My mother described being a parent
as something that makes your life far more amazing and far more difficult
than you could've ever possibly imagined.
I've been trying to help corals become parents for over 10 years now.
And watching the wonder of life
has certainly filled me with amazement to the core of my soul.
But I've also seen how difficult it is for them to become parents.
The pillar corals spawned again two weeks ago,
and we collected their eggs and brought them back to the lab.
And here you see one embryo dividing,
alongside 14 eggs that didn't fertilize
and will blow up.
They'll be infected with bacteria, they will explode
and those bacteria will threaten the life of this one embryo
that has a chance.
We don't know if it was our handling methods that went wrong
and we don't know
if it was just this coral on this reef, always suffering from low fertility.
Whatever the cause,
we have much more work to do before we can use baby corals
to grow or fix or, yes, maybe save coral reefs.
So never mind that they're worth hundreds of billions of dollars.
Coral reefs are hardworking animals and plants and microbes and fungi.
They're providing us with art and food and medicine.
And we almost took out an entire generation of corals.
But a few made it anyway, despite our best efforts,
and now it's time for us to thank them for the work they did
and give them every chance they have to raise the coral reefs of the future,
their coral babies.
Thank you so much.
(Applause)